[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire la question trans divise le
peler les psy comme les intellectuels
six personnes discutent le droit de
changer de sexe beaucoup s'inquiètent de
transition trop presque trop précoce
comme dans le documentaire petite fille
de sébastien lifshitz ou du casse-tête
occasionnés par les changements
d'identité de genre en effet depuis 2016
en france on peut changer d'état civil
sans avoir à justifier de traitements
médicaux ou d'opérations chirurgicales
la preuve de l'irréversibilité du
changement de sexe n'est plus requise si
bien qu'il y a des trans femmes qui sont
en train d'accoucher en ce moment des
trans pardon des trans up qui sont en
train d'accoucher en ce moment et et des
trans femme à qui l'on refuse d'être la
mère de leur enfant elles peuvent en
être le père mais pas la mer alors que
l'état civil les reconnaît comme femme
et puis il ya des problèmes concernant
les compétitions sportives féminines où
les espaces réservés aux femmes en
général les trans femmes doivent-elles y
avoir accès pour en débattre nous avons
invité sylvia lippi vous êtes
psychanalyste on vous doit notamment
rythme et mélancolie aux éditions erès
et avec d'autres psychanalyste vous avez
signé une tribune dans locks pour
répondre à une autre tribune de site
dénonçant les transitions sexuelles
précoces
cette première tribune s'attaquer aux
documentaires petite fille de sébastien
lifshitz dont vous avez pris la défense
alors puisque c'est souvent par là que
le débat commence à propos des
transitions précoce ses enfants
transgenres qui ne subissent pas
d'opération se fait rhji chalmé qui
disent qu'ils sont nés dans le mauvais
corps qui voudrait qu'à l'école on leur
donne un autre prénom et qui voudraient
aussi qu'on bloque leur puberté et les
votre position en deux bouts on va en
parler william demant bien sûrement moi
je dirais tout simplement il faut
écouter l'enfant c'est à dire il n'ya
pas des traditions de précoce
si la personne un peu faire une
expérience expérimenter les corps comme
on les voit d'aller de commentaire si
d'un côté puis de la petite fille vous
l'appelez la scène initiale au il
expérimente y laissa et il a en vente
son corps et à la fin elle dit peut-être
un robin ont peut-être un chapeau donc
c'est tout c'est pas cela c'est là les
moments importants une fois qu'elles en
feront peu expérimentés vivre et
découvrir échanger même les habitudes à
ce point là on ne peut pas parler des
transitions de précoce on ne peut pas
marie jo bonnet vous êtes d'historienne
militante historique de la cause
féministe vous avez participé à la
naissance du fmb l'efs vous avez gré
créer les rouges vous avez
publié à dieu les rebelles chez
flammarion au simone de beauvoir et les
femmes chez albin michel et vous faites
partie des signataires avec elisabeth
badinter chantal delsol catherine dolto
de la tribune une autre tribune parue
dans l'express une cinquantaine de psy
de médecins et d'intellectuels dénonce
je cite une emprise idéologique sur le
corps des enfants fait au nom de
l'émancipation de l'enfant transgenres
là aussi c'était à propos du film petite
fille de sébastien lifshitz alors vous
votre position sur ces transitions sur
ses enfants transgenres
en deux mots oui je pense qu'un enfant
ne peut pas être en chambre parce que
c'est un peu tôt pour décider si qu'est
ce que c'est qu'un genre si vous
demandez à un enfant ce que ça signifie
ça m'étonnerait qu'il ait une réponse
comment dire
satisfaisante bois tous les enfants
enfin moi même quand j'étais enfant tout
le monde se pose la question de son
identité sexuelle moi j'étais réputé
garçon manqué parce que j'étais une
petite fille qui sortait de l'ordinaire
donc le problème si vous voulez c'est la
différence
il ya plein d'enfants surtout
aujourd'hui il ya de plus en plus
d'enfants qui sont différents les uns
des autres qui échappe au moule alors
est ce qu'il faut pour autant les
médicalisé dès l'âge de 10 ans 11 ans
moi je trouve ça vraiment très très
dangereux parce que c'est la porte
ouverte vraiment oublié ou pouvoir que
dénoncer déjà foucault et
c'est une médicalisation de tous les
actes de la vie ça il ya quelque chose
qui va pas du tout parce que l'identité
c'est quelque chose qui se travaille qui
évolue qui est âgé selon dit selon sa
propre histoire personnelle et dans le
film par exemple la petite fille il est
clair que la mère avait un rôle très
important dans ceux dont dans ce
changement d'identité parce que c'était
elle qui poussait son fils devenir une
petite fille
donc vous voyez c'est très complexe on
peut pas comme ça uniquement en dire que
l'enfant il a c'est une parole
sa parole est d'or non je pense que il
faut il faut laisser les choses évoluer
c'est il est en grande transformation
l'enfant donc il faut lui la paix
je dirais
lexsi agresti vous est la fondatrice du
compte instagram militant intitulé
aggressively france suivie par plus de
cinquante mille personnes c'est vous qui
avez écrit une histoire de genre paru
chez marabout en février dernier quel
est votre point de vue alors sur ses sur
ses enfants
les xive
il est important de rendre à l'enfant et
de regarder l'enfant comme un sujet
moins que comme un objet et que bien
souvent quand il s'agit d'exprimer
effectivement ce rapport à l'identité
qui est en construction et qui est
fluide aucune identité de genre est une
donnée qui est imperméable et immuable
il faut pouvoir offrir des outils
notamment les outils que l'enfant
réclame la plupart du temps ils ne sont
pas médicaux et d'ailleurs la
législation ne permet pas qu'on mutilent
les enfants comme on peut parfois
l'entendre les pratiques sont encadrés
aucune pratique qui est offerte aux
mineurs n'est irréversible
je crois qu'il ya un vrai manque
d'objectivité sur la question des
transitions offertes aux enfants et que
quand on parle de manipulation
idéologique créer la grande peur des
méchants trans qui transformerait les
enfants quand il existe des équipes
encadrantes de spécialistes
endocrinologue psychiatre dans les
équipes qui finalement n'inclut pas de
transe et la communauté le dénonce
souvent c'est manquer d'objectivité
le fait de ne pas permettre un accès à
ces outils d'expression de son genre et
d'expérimentation son genre comme le
disait ana c'est aussi prendre le risque
de jouer avec la santé mentale d'adultes
en développement la santé la commission
pour la santé mentale du canada avait
très clairement montré que une
intégration et un accès à ces outils que
soit le prénom que ce soit les vêtements
dès l'enfance et l'adolescence
permettait de de virtuellement supprimer
les tentatives de suicide quand on
arrive à l'âge adulte et je crois que
c'est une donnée que personne ne peut
refuser finalement quand on comprend ce
qu'elle est ce qu'elle implique n'a
cogné vous êtes psychologue clinicienne
vous aussi comme marie jo bonnet vous
avez signé la tribune parue dans
l'express contre les transitions
sexuelle chez les enfants et vous êtes
membre de l'observatoire des discours
idéologiques sur l'enfant et
l'adolescent qui s'est élevé lui aussi
contre le parti-pris militant je vous
cite du film de sébastien lifshitz
petite fille alors notre position avoue
personnel
alors ma position personnelle et ceux ci
celle du collectif que je représente
aujourd'hui elle est que évidemment
l'enfant est un être en développement en
construction et que tout ce qu'on peut
vouloir faire à son corps et alors là
pour le coup je reprendrai ce que ce que
voilà les autres collègues la du jour on
dit c'est que bien sûr que c'est que
beaucoup de choses irréversibles sont
faites sur des enfants mineurs
premier exemple qu'on peut donner et là
c'est tout à fait légal en france dès 14
ans 15 ans 16 ans on peut proposer à des
enfants dans leur parcours de transition
des hormones antagonistes à leurs
hormones
naturelles qui ont été bloqués par des
bloqueurs la puberté et donc ses
hormones elle ou des conséquences tout à
fait irréversible sur le développement
il va y avoir par exemple faut les
filles la voix grave la pilosité le
développement du clitoris qui peuvent
alors prendre une taille très importante
et ça c'est irréversible par exemple
donc oui non peut pas dire que rien
n'est fait sur le corps de l'enfant je
vois là bien sûr qu'il ya des choses qui
se sont certainement encadrer ce qu'on
dénonce c'est que sur le modèle des
états unis de la suède qui maintenant
revient en plus sur cette méthode pour
la suède pour la grande bretagne il est
question de ne faire que de la thérapie
affirmative donc l'idée c'est qu'on va
amener à des enfants
à être immédiatement dans le train trans
c'est à dire que on commence on prend
des bloqueurs la puberté ont fait une
transition sociale et tout ça amène
nécessairement à un moment à des
transitions médical qu'il allait vers
irréversible et c'est bien sûr ça qui
nous inquiète
à l'adolescence nous paraît pas possible
que des enfants sachent exactement ce
qu'ils peuvent souhaiter pour la suite
les mineurs le statut de mineur il
existe justement pour protéger les
enfants de décisions qui seraient trop
radicales et la thérapie affirma-t-il
est trop radical
yoli bi bas je suis complètement en
désaccord avec ma collègue pour l'eau
raisons d'abord disons éthiques nous
sommes des psychanalystes psychologues
et je ne comprends pas pourquoi dans ces
derniers temps on est devenu des
contrôleurs des gemini et cliquer des
pères qui se préoccupent qui ont cette
fonction là alors que nous devions gérer
pète avant les fonctions d' écoute
écoute n'est pas ma région l'enfant
parle il décide c'est pas du tout ça
c'est prendre les temps un com comme
vous vous disiez tout à l'heure les
temps d voire dé permettre au sujet des
expérimentés son corps expérimenter son
col savait pas dire lui donner tout de
suite des médicaments c'est ça qui est
incroyable on dirait que nos collègues
psychiatre et psychanalyste qui suit
nous nous mêmes qui nous suivons des
enfants ou des adolescents en transition
qui ont soit la com qui on traite les
enfants comme des objets qui on est là
pour leur dire tout de suite s'il doit
être au mont femmes c'est n'est pas
comme ça qui se passe
nos enfants ne vont pas vive moi je n'ai
jamais eu un enfant ou un adolescent qui
met dis tout de suite je veux ça je veux
là non ils sont entre ans il y en a même
qui disent moi je ne veux pas intervenir
sur mon corps je veux simplement ça
éprouvé cette sensation qu'est ce que ça
veut dire éprouvé quelle je veux change
ilyena qui change des des gens
qui changent de nom d'autre qui ne les
changent pas je veux dire il y à une
telle diversité et ce n'est pas tout
parce que en réalité cette diversité
pourquoi est devenu vraiment dix auront
là la question des transidentités est
devenue une question fondamentale pour
la psychanalyse à ce que personnellement
j'ai vraiment changé ma façon d diriger
les cures avec les autres et passion
aussi c'est à dire on a été tellement
fort mais à la binarité à 7/10 on cite
cage un mix avaler n'importe qui est la
femme qui dit je ne peux pas être là la
jeune femme qui dirige je ne peux pas
être avec cet homme parce qu'ils gagnent
pas plus que moi voilà tipping de la
binarité les hommes doivent gagner plus
que les femmes ou à l'autre l'autre et
l'autre un jeune homme qui dit cette
femme quand même il est un peu grosse
mais
dans les cas la personne aussi est gros
et donc je ne lui dis pas directement
mais je lui dis par exemple mais vous
aussi
ah oui mais moi je suis un homme voyez
on est tellement dans cette catégorie 1
donc dans cette fixation des binarité
que je trouve que la transidentité qui
n'est pas simplement les changements des
sexes mais c'est un monde complètement
disons des découvertes d'invention jeu
les diplômés fois dans mes articles et
cette onction d'enfants d'en vanter son
propre record et nous sommes là en tant
que petit à dire ça nous on ne peut pas
il faut protéger il va décider après
mais jamais on est au point avec sa
propre identité jamais c'est pas parce
que on a 18 ans qui ont cessé clooney
qu'est les sujets ces rencontres l'effet
des sujets tivité alors là c'est
important c'est à dire simplement
attendre de fer ou accessoires et ça
c'est là pour moi c'est ce qui nous
enseignait freud dans notre pratique et
je vais continuer de cette façon on
n'est pas prendre la figure disons la
position d'alger mini cricket pour
pinocchio où je sais pas dans docteur
méchant ou gentil qui pense au futur qui
imagine le futur de l'âme alors badge
abonnés
oui mais moi je ne comprends pas ce que
vous appelez expérimenter son corps a
inventé son corps je veux dire on est
dans un corps et tout le monde
l'expérimentent je veux dire et le corps
c'est un ensemble d'énergie c'est un
ensemble de désir je comprends pas très
bien ce que ce qu'il ya de différent
dans cette expérimentation est ce que
vous pouvez donner un peu plus de
précision s'il vous plaît
oui balma quand je dis expérimentés je
répète dans la vie je prends une petite
fille parce que j'imagine que vous
l'avez vu alors j'ai pris précise tout
de suite que je n'étais pas du tout
d'accord je les cuis d'ailleurs dans un
article est disponible soit même avec
patrice que j'étais avec patrice
maniglier je veux dire l'intervention
par exemple de la psychiatre qui est
ensuite hissé dysphorique sept ans que
la personne ne dise folique la petite
fille et d'historique ou alors c'est que
vous disiez tout à l'heure être né dans
un mauvais accord il ya un très bon et
ces deux sociologues france mais
qu'elles me seck il explique très bien
qu est ce que ça veut dire cette idée
dans sept à dix ans cette façon médical
des traités les transidentité avec cette
sortie guidée de dire on est dans un
mauvais accord et c'est pas du tout ça
en tronçonné pas né dans un mauvais
corps je vais l'appeler petite fille
sasha n'étaient pas nés dans son mauvais
score c'est ceux qui lui disaient les
frères c'est ce qui tout le monde lui
disait parce qu'ils ne pouvaient rien
faire or et non les cas des petites
filles s'il aurait pu par exemple
s'habiller en fille est allée à l'école
habillé en fille après on verra
simplement il est oubliée elle est
obligée d'aller à l'école abbey a une
petite fille simplement quand il ya les
tampons du psychiatre elle peut aller
s'il ya les psychiatres qui dit oui et
c'est ces mécanismes là qui empêche
notamment
c'est que j'ai c'est que je dis des
expérimentés et voir qu'elle sait qu'il
sera prêt on n'est pas obligé je suis
d'accord avec vous j'imagine des deux
cités il ne s'agit pas d'aider dès lé
sexe de l'enfant dès les cinq enfants il
s'agit de lui permettre d essayer à
aider se sentir bien avec les corps qui
est en train d'inventer tout le monde
invente son corps et l'étrange aussi
mais alors justement quand vous dites il
a le droit d'expérimenter il n'est pas
question de décider se pose la question
de tous les traitements éventuellement
ou qu'il faisait allusion à n'a cogné
mais aussi lexsi agresti et qu'on peut
ou que l'on ne peut pas donner à ses
enfants mineurs et qui eux effectivement
on pourrait rendre ou pas irréversible
un certain type de changement alors vous
n'étiez pas d'accord toutes les deux
alexis agresti et ea n'a cogné est-ce
qu'on peut ou pas
faire des choses irréversibles sur son
corps
sur son genre quand on est enfant une
fille
alors quand on est enfin je crois qu'il
ya effectivement un relativisme qui doit
être pris en compte et il est les
équipes existent a encore une fois je
crois aussi que il ya eu je constate
dans les discours de mes collègues ce
soir une difficulté à penser
peut-être plus en multi dimension à la
fois la donne et de sexe est la donnée
de genre qui sont très très indépendante
finalement et qui sont très variables à
la fois dans le temps et dans l'espace
je crois qu'il est nécessaire de prendre
en compte quand on parle de trans
identité la donnée anthropologique qui
nous montre à quel point en fait on est
dans l'effectif dans la construction
dans qui dépend aussi d'un contexte et
de normes qui sont très locales qui sont
très temporelles de son genre et de son
corps les deux données existent les deux
données se construisent elles se
construisent dans un rapport à l'autre
et de ce qui est dit de ce qui peut
exister
et bien souvent en fait on entend à peu
près ce qui se dit ce soir c'est que il
est pas possible de pouvoir décider
quand on sort d'une majorité moi je sais
et je crois qu'il est important
d'entendre la voix des personnes traces
parce que je crois qu'il ya une
légitimité de notre parole et de nos
observations à qui doit être reconnu ce
que je constate depuis mon petit point
de vue c'est que si j'avais eu accès
effectivement plus facilement à ne
serait-ce qu des vêtements sans parler
de l'irréversibilité ne serait ce qu'à
la possibilité de réfléchir à changer de
prénom quand j'étais jeune ça aurait été
trois tentatives de suicide en moins ça
aurait été un sentiment d'inadéquation
en moins je le constate aussi on a
encore
perdu une jeune femme trans qui avec
clairement le sentiment de ne pas
pouvoir exister et je crois que
finalement au-delà de d'un parti pris
idéologique au delà de positionnement
politique cette réalité de je ne me sens
pas le droit d'exister elle doit juste à
30 ans du humainement ensuite on doit
lui trouver des outils il ya des outils
sociaux qui existent ensuite des outils
médicaux qui existe j'ai le droit en
tant qu individu majeur et éclairé de
décider que des choses seront faites qui
seront irréversibles pour moi je je je
crois que c'est pas un droit qui est
abusive je crois qu'il ne fait de mal à
personne d'autre parce que je crois que
ce mouvement de
2,2 de conversion dont on entend parfois
parler finalement il est largement
surestimée qu'il existe une panique qui
des personnes si ce genre des personnes
l'on transfère à la possibilité d'une
libre expression notre minorité et que
finalement ça ça on utilise l'argument
du corps on utilise l'argument du sexe
comme une sorte de
2,2 d'appel au bon sens d'appel à la
nature alors que bien souvent ce qui a
demandé n'est pas du tout de cet ordre
là j'aimerais que ça soit entendu je
crois que ça l'est trop peu mieux connu
oui moi je suis tout à fait d'accord sur
l'idée qu' il faut être conscient qu'il
ya des enfants qui souffrent vraiment
d'une dysphorie de genre est importante
et que une population très vulnérable
leixia raison beaucoup d'études ont
montré la question que nous qui nous
intéresse vraiment c'est que le type de
réponse qui est donnée aux enfants
devient unilatérale bien entendu que ces
enfants ont besoin d'être accompagnés
d'être entouré par un environnement
bienveillant tolérant qui acceptent
leurs difficultés qui s'adapte aussi à
une société qui en mouvance en ce moment
mais il se passe quand même quelque
chose c'est que je le répète il va y
avoir et on le voit dans le documentaire
petite fille
bien finalement un petit garçon qui
demande à être considérée comme une
petite fille à devenir une petite fille
bon à la maison peu et c'est à l'école
il peut passer des choses peut-être
qu'il faut décider mais qu'est ce qui se
passe il avoir une pédopsychiatre qui en
un rendez-vous lui dis y'a pas de
problème tu es une petite fille les
prochains rendez vous on va voir
l'endocrinologue pour savoir à quel
moment on te donne des blocs à la
puberté au stade taner 2 voilà c'est à
dire 10 ans 11 ans 12 ans donc c'est
quand même très précoce
et il ya une autre donnée qui est quand
même tout à fait importante à souligner
c'est que depuis dix ans elle a toutes
les études le montrent il y à une
augmentation exponentielle des demandes
de de transition
voilà on n'est pas complètement foutu on
se doute bien que en grande partie il
s'agit d'un coming out qui est enfin
autorisé pour des personnes qui
probablement auparavant ne se seraient
pas autorisés à ça
mais la population a changé il s'avère
que contrairement à auparavant 80 % sont
des adolescentes fille
et la question évidemment fondamental
des réseaux sociaux de l' influence de
la psychopathologie adolescente qui est
en souffrance et ils cherchent une
solution pour pour enfin sortir de cette
souffrance et qui se dit pas peut-être
que ça ce serait bien qu'ils explorent
pourquoi pas mais qu'on leur propose pas
de manière systématique ce qui commence
à être le cas alors aux etats-unis dans
plein d'autres pays mais qui commence à
être coté en france aussi une réponse
qui soit affirmative et qui entraîne
immédiatement les boules quand la
puberté les hormones antagonistes et
cetera et cetera quand j'ai commencé on
se rend compte que finalement dans la
plupart des cas à les jeunes vont
jusqu'au bout
et c'était pas le cas quand on faisait
des thérapies qu'était qui repoussait un
peu dans le temps en fait c'était même
pour tout à fait l' inverse et on sait
maintenant qu'il ya aussi des gens qui
des transitions
et qui accuse on pense aux cadeaux kerra
belle en angleterre qui accuse quand
même et qui accueille un procès avec la
tavistock clinique à propos de ce
traitement qu'elle considère qu'elle a
reçu beaucoup trop jeunes qu'on n'a pas
entendu qu'elle était sa vraie
souffrance et que maintenant et bien
voilà elle a été traités avec des
hormones mâles elle elle aimerait être
être à nouveau une femme et elle peut
elle peut plus tout à fait plus comme
elle aurait voulu elle a plus de
poitrine et donc tout ça pour elle c'est
une grande souffrance et effectivement
on l'a mis sous zohra mal à 16 ans mais
que j'ai agresti vous l'entendez très
souvent c'est ça qui inquiète c'est de
se dire mais bien sûr on peut s'il se
trompe et qu'il le regrette ensuite
alors la question de jean temps les
inquiétudes et je crois qu'elles font
absolument logique
je crois qu'il est aussi raisonnable de
réfléchir communément ces questions je
crois que l'une des pistes de réponses
potentielles c'est la façon dont on
définit
en fait ce qu'est la transidentité et
que bien souvent quand on cherche à à le
comprendre on a tout de suite ces
définitions qui sont médicales qui sont
psychiatrique vous aviez vous avez
mentionné la question de la dysphorie on
a sept sur pathologisation des trans
identité qui fait qu'il n'ya pas du tout
de dialogue qui a pas du tout de
discours qui a pas du tout de réflexion
d'ordre culturel fort ce que peuvent
être les genres qui fait que la seule
réponse qui nous est donné finalement
c'est cette prise en charge et je crois
qu'on peut mentionner tous les contre
exemples qu'on veut moi par exemple je
ne veux pas de chirurgie génitale j'ai
gelé j'en ai pris conscience je crois
que le fait aussi qu'on le dise si peu
on peut être une femme sans avoir un
vagin sans avoir une vulve que les
transitions ne doivent pas suivre un
modèle biologique un modèle schéma
corporel
peut-être que ça offre un espace de
réflexion qui permet de penser le genre
comme ce que mentionné ann à cette
question d'une fluidité identitaire qui
va ensuite potentiellement s'ancrer sur
certains détails corporelle et pas
d'autres on parle ici de trans identité
on parle absolument pas des personnes
l'ont binaire qui existent pourtant on
parle aussi de l'augmentation de
statistiques du nombre plus important de
transition et de des transitions de
demandes de prise en charge je crois
qu'on a un discours qui reste très
centrés sur notre petite société
occidentale et que finalement c'est
l'évolution de ces normes des genres
dans notre contexte qui fait qu'il ya
une évolution des demandes et qui a une
difficulté à comprendre vraiment quelles
sont les demandes quand on prend des cas
un peu fade qui sortent de notre
contexte si on s'intéresse aux personnes
tous spirit dans ce que sont les états
unis actuelle si on s'intéresse au cas
de la polynésie on prend conscience que
quand on a un contexte culturel un
contexte de société qui réfléchit le
genre de base non pas comme une donnée
absolument figé qui s'ancre dans la
biologie on a la possibilité
d'expression de personnes qui ne
demandent pas à changer forcément de
corps et que si on considère le problème
il est je vous interromps parce que
c'est la pause est obligatoire juste
maintenant je vous redonne la parole
juste après
[Musique]
la france et d'autres pays du globe
doivent faire face à une pénurie de main
d'oeuvre comment expliquer ce phénomène
depuis tout temps vous avez eu un taux
de chômage important et puis en revanche
des demandes des entreprises pour
engager des gens et qui ne se
rencontraient pas parce que formation
insuffisante parce que
inadéquation entre des gens qui étaient
sur le marché du travail est ce que
cherchait les entreprises et à chaque
reprise économique on bute sur des
normes pénurie de main d'oeuvre si on
répond pas tout de suite avec la
concurrence il peut y avoir des
effondrements de certains pans de notre
activité c'est un phénomène sur lequel
il faut travailler sur le temps long
malheureusement le connaissez tous le
temps politique il n'est pas en temps
longs il les entend élections par
élections
[Musique]
en afghanistan le passage du pouvoir aux
talibans après vingt ans de guerre est
une défaite pour l'ensemble des
occidentaux en tant que membre de l'otan
un pays comme la france peut se poser
des questions sur la vision américaine
de l'organisation et la prise de
contrôle du marché des sous marins
australiens par les états unis montrent
qu'une alliance entre anglo saxons pour
faire face à la chine est en train de se
construire c'est un signe manifeste
d'une longue dégringolade de notre
posture à la fois stratégiques
politiques sur la scène internationale
et industriels aussi les pays européens
sont ils perçus comme des pourvoyeurs de
troupes de supplétifs au service des
états unis ou bien des alliés et de
véritables partenaires
[Musique]
on va prendre ce débat avec sylvia lippi
qui était assise à côté de moi avec
marie jo bonnet avec les bixi agresti et
anne n'a cogné
je vous mets fournit la transition et
lexie investi je vais revenir sur la loi
de 2016 qui a changé en france mais dans
beaucoup d'autres pays également on n'a
plus besoin de changer de sexe de
manière irréversible en prenant des
hormones ou en se faisant opérer pour
changer de genre l état civil on peut
être une femme l état civil avec des
organes sexuels masculins et vice versa
on peut donc faire des enfants dont on
est le père alors qu'on est une femme à
l'état civil est donc demandé d'en être
la mère ce changement il est
considérable lexie je vous redonne la
parole quelques instants il est d'autant
plus considérable que le plupart des
jolies niort
oui bien souvent et je crois que ce que
les gens ignorent aussi c'est que
finalement ce qui nous était demandé
implicitement c'est une stérilisation
forcée quand on voulait juste avoir un
statut de genre social qui était
pleinement le nôtre je crois que c'est
une forme de donner aux organismes qui
est très politique et qui revêt une
façon et qui dévoile une façon de lire
la possibilité
d'avoir une existence et de pouvoir
aussi participé à des traits culturels
qui sont particulièrement symbolique
chez nous comme la parentalité qui nous
était finalement retiré comme des
personnes comme des sortes de citoyens
de seconde classe
moi je crois qu'il était plus que
nécessaire et d'ailleurs la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme avait
condamné la france
ce changement n'avait pas oui et c'est
pour ça que la loi a effectivement
changé
je crois encore que ce que ça révèle
c'est toujours les mêmes paradigmes
toujours les mêmes façons de réfléchir
cette dichotomie du corps et de
l'identité et du genre moi je me
considère pas du tout comme ayant un
corps d'homme ayons des organes génitaux
masculins et et je crois pas que le fait
que j'ai un pénis face de moi le père
d'un enfant que je pourrais
potentiellement avoir un jour
je crois que c'est vraiment encore une
fois cette façon qu'on a de
conceptualiser ensemble le genre
culturellement qui bloque
fondamentalement alors réaction marie jo
bonnet pour vous est-ce que c'est un
problème ça aujourd'hui parce que comme
le dit lexsi demain elle peut faire un
enfant
dont elle sera considéré comme le père
par l'état civil alors que l'état civil
lui peut la considérer parfaitement
comme une femme non mais attendez on
marche sur la tête là il est de toute
évidence
il elle ne sera pas la mère de cet
enfant parce qu elle ne le met pas aux
bourdes donc il faut quand même rester
sur la dent les choses quand même
concrète de la réalité du corps je veux
dire qu'est ce que c'est une mère c'est
quelqu'un qui met au monde un enfant
ça c'est quand même indépassable à mon
avis alors évidemment vous avez les
biotechnologies et qui tripote et que
celle qui tripotent tout ça et on peut
on va faire des enfants même avec des
utérus artificiel
ça va bientôt être le moment mais je
pense que quand même il ya plusieurs
questions qui se posent moi
personnellement que un enfant désire
mettre des robes ou des pantalons qui
désirent changer de prénom ça
personnellement ça mais je trouve ça
vraiment c'est peut le faire qu'ils le
fassent le problème pour moi commence
avec les bloqueurs de puberté avec le
problème de l' intrusion pharmaceutique
l'intrusion hormonal parce qu'on va
avoir affaire à des gens qui prennent
des hormones toute leur vie jusqu'à la
mort alors je sais pas si vous vous
rendez compte pour les industries
pharmaceutiques c'est le jackpot à ces
merveilleux et d'ailleurs on s'aperçoit
que les industries pharmaceutiques ont
une action très importante pour pour
faire passer des lois nouvelles et donc
je pense qu'il faut d'abord analyser on
n'est pas uniquement dans la question
identitaire
on est dans un ensemble dans une
économie 1 dans une économie qui cherche
à faire des profits et les hormones
c'est magnifique là ça c'est le premier
point deuxième point leslie
vous avez vous êtes en train de
développer moi ce que j'appelle
l'idéologie américaine du seul ce making
donc l'auto construction de soi même
je pense que nous sommes inscrits dans
une histoire ne peut pas effacer
l'histoire on est né dans un pays on est
né dans une famille il ya il ya
l'inconscient qui existent l'inconscient
familiale je dirais même manipulé par
l'inconscient familiale et de notre pays
donc on peut pas comme ça à dire voilà
je mon genre c'est pas le bien je suis
une femme avec un pénis et donc je vais
pouvoir à devenir la mère de mon enfant
je lire là il ya quelque chose qui
déraille excusez moi à leslie de le dire
je ne suis pas d'accord avec vous voilà
voyez parce que franchement
pour les enfants comment les enfants
comment ils vont se repérer dans la
liesse et quand même un sérieux problème
qu'est ce que ça va donner dans leur
tête on va poser la question à sauviat
libye déjà c'est qui est intéressant moi
dans ce qu'ils disent elles éxigé je
n'entendais pas du tout en self made
body 1 j'entendais plutôt comme on dira
encore que comme dit tout à l'heure peut
avoir à faire un corps et un genre et
bien sûr on est tous d'accord c'est pas
la même chose
mais la question c'est comment ces corps
et ses genres 1 peuvent tenir ensemble à
partir de désirs inconscients donc à
partir de là je veux dire il y à des
mères qui n'ont pas porté les enfants un
prénom des mères lesbiennes qui n'ont
pas porté l'enfant et pourtant elles
sont elles sont ds voilà et donc c'est
pour ça ils sont quand même des mers 1
donc la question à mon avis c'est qu'ils
aient encore une fois et je réponds un
peu ce que je disais tout à l'heure ça
l'inconscient n'a pas des sexes et n'a
pas des genres donc à partir de là à
partir de là les possibilités la
possibilité d n sexe fait partie de
notre monde et réduire toujours à
l'effet qu'il ya des changements à des
sociétés et pas simplement des individus
aussi des personnes ne veut pas dire
qu'il s'est toujours ses fantasmes
néolibérale c'est toujours la faute de
l'autre
donc tout est possible
les industries pharmaceutiques moi j'ai
travaillé en psychiatrie depuis 15 ans
et j'étais quand même étonné à qui on
donne des neuroleptiques à gogo en dés
que quelqu'un va mal on lui donne les
neuroleptiques des antidépresseurs et
des anxiolytiques qui sont pour certains
versent irréversible il n'y a jamais eu
ces tapages qui lie à avec la question
trans ça ça m'interroge la ritaline oui
les psys ils se sont un peu le honni ils
ont montré qu'ils étaient un peu à d un
peu à des accords mais je n'ai jamais vu
la série des tribunes à contre les
transitions qu'ai je vu des puits les
derniers temps à des plus petits films
et même avant donc c'est ça qui
m'interrogent qu'est ce qui fait que
nous les psy on est si sensible à cette
question et à est pas tous les autres on
va poser un question a cogné qui plient
également
oui et moi je pense que c'est une
une erreur sylvia de penser que que
c'est spécifiquement la question trans
qui nous qui nous interpelle déjà parce
que si vous allez voir sur notre site
tous s'intéressent aussi à d'autres
sujets justement sur du surdiagnostic
sur la ritaline et c'est donc évidemment
qu'il ya d'autres choses qui nous
interroge je pense que vraiment j'ai
besoin de me répéter donc c'est la
question l'irréversibilité des
traitements de décisions qui sont
irrémédiables que on propose à des
enfants sur leur identité donc sur leur
construction me voilà je pense pas
effectivement que tous les traitements
sont achetés à la poubelle et bien
certainement pleins de cas où ces
transitions sont très bien certainement
la majorité quand il s'agit d'adultes
je suis certaine que la ritaline peut
avoir une certaine efficacité pour
certains enfants etc le problème c'est
la réponse globale unilatérale qui
aurait que ça mais et donc je pense que
c'est pour ça que là on sort on promet
justement là on parle de quelque chose
qui n'est pas irréversible qui est le
fait qu'on peut changer d'état civil
aujourd'hui sans avoir eu besoin de
prendre ni des hormones ni de se faire
opérer avec les le boulot casse tête
juridique que cela provoque puisque on a
affaire à des trans femmes qui sont
considérés comme des femmes à l'état
civil des trans hommes qui sont
considérés comme des hommes à l'état
civil mais mais ses transes hommes
peuvent demain à coucher
avoir un enfant qu'ils en sortent du
vente
donc
quel est votre sentiment votre position
c'est difficile là pour moi de vous
répondre vraiment parce qu'au final on
s'est beaucoup intéressé à la question
des mineurs et un et - à la question un
des adultes donc je suis pas certaine
d'avoir un point de vue vraiment
représentatifs cette question je
comprends tout à fait à la fois la
question du désir qu'il ya d'avoir la
vie qu'on souhaite avec les
représentations de soi qu'on peut
souhaiter et en même temps je ne suis
pas étonné ni spécialement choqué que
les choses prennent du temps on est un
pays en france où pour des raisons
éthiques on prend le temps de réfléchir
de voir à ce qui se passe le mieux ça ne
veut pas dire qu'on ne fait pas les
choses mais je pense qu on a besoin
aussi d'une certaine temporalité pour
que les choses se passent pas tout le
temps par la force ça peut être
frustrant et ça peut être désagréable
mais je ne crois pas que ce soit une
attitude voilà transphobes de la part
d'aidé des pouvoirs publics voilà hors
jeu tente mais mais plutôt que tout ça
c'est très nouveau c'est des questions
qui se posent quand même depuis assez
peu de temps est maintenant de manière
massive et donc bien sûr qu'il faut un
peu le temps de réfléchir à ce qui
pourrait se passer le mieux concernant
les compétitions sportives féminines
ouvert aux autres ans femmes
majeau bonnet vous aviez réagi au moment
où la fédération de française de rugby a
accepté que dans les compétitions
féminines y ait des trans femmes c'est
pourquoi ça vous sembler injuste vous
n'êtes pas la seule à
navratilova s'en est indigné aussi au
tennis il ya eu énormément de cas où je
rappelle que aux jeux olympiques par
exemple on peut s'inscrire enfin on peut
courir dans une compétition sportive
féminine quand on est à une transe femme
et qu'on a gardé ses organes sexuels
masculins est une question de
testostérone c'est ça qui est mesuré et
en fonction du taux de testostérone on
va vous acceptez ou pas
oui mais vous en vous remarquerez que
vous n'avez pas de 30 hommes
c'est-à-dire deux femmes deux femmes
tout mail dans les dents les équipes de
rugby masculine ni en train de courir le
100 m avec les hommes
donc je pense que c'est un problème
alors là pour le coup c'est un problème
féministe parce que vous avez un certain
nombre de transferts qui colonisent les
territoires féminin est toutefois tout
en prônant une image de la féminité qui
est très traditionnel très conventionnel
et cette image de la féminité nous
l'avons combattu moi j'allais combattu
tout le temps enfin je veux dire
est donc le problème si vous voulez
c'est comme disait marc et martina
navratilova c'est de la concurrence
déloyale parce que les trans femmes donc
on la même force musculaire masculine
puisqu'ils ont pas
puisqu'ils se disent enfin
ceux qui n'ont pas transitionner
jusqu'au bout si je puis dire ont gardé
leur force musculaire donc vous allez
pas les accepter dans des équipes de
rugby le rugby est un sport très récent
je veux dire le sport féminin les femmes
an à peine acquis le droit de faire du
rugby et du football etc
donc vous allez autoriser les hommes à
venir dans les équipes moi je trouve ça
quand même très inquiétant au niveau des
droits des femmes parce que d'un côté on
reconnaît les droits des transgenres à
l'identité de genre mais aux dépens des
droits des femmes aux dépens de l'or du
sport féminin au dépend de beaucoup de
choses comme par exemple les toilettes
n'est présent voyez il n'y a plus aucun
territoire où les femmes sont en train y
compris d'ailleurs les associations de
lesbienne parce que moi j'ai été
contacté par plusieurs jeunes femmes qui
sont harcelés quand vous avez des trans
là alors là c'est uniquement le trans
activisme qui veulent absolument coucher
avec elle tout en ayant un sexe masculin
alors et quand elle refuse c'est quand
même un droit élémentaire elles sont
traitées de transforme alors vous voyez
là il ya quand même une limite une ligne
rouge qui a été dépassé et là ça pose un
vrai problème de respect de l'autre et
de respect des territoires féminin gers
et la féminité le problème c'est la
féminité qui est qui et n'y est qui et
qui est rejeté je gère notre société a
un problème avec la féminité voilà on
croyait qu'on avait gagné tous les
droits des femmes et qui voudra ce n'est
pas vrai de la question trans pose la
question de la féminité vous avez 70 %
de jeunes filles qui veulent
transitionner vers les hommes pourquoi
parce que elle rejette leur propre
féminité marie-jo donc c'est pas 60 % à
60 % des jeunes filles 1 vous êtes parmi
ceux qui veulent garder celles qui
veulent transitionner il ya 60%
décidé ça pourrait très bien
je vais dire au port on en est mais
parmi effectivement les personnes qui
veulent transitionnelle qui vont dans
les cliniques de genre etc vous avez
donc 70 % de filles ça pose un problème
et parmi ces filles vous en avez
beaucoup qui n'acceptent pas leur
homosexualité et donc qu'ils pensent que
en devenant 30 hommes eh bien ce sera
beaucoup plus facile de vivre avec une
femme donc vous voyez le genre de
problème que sa femme pose pour moi
c'est une vraie régression
sociale parce qu'on avait réussi à ce
que l'homosexualité soit acceptée dans
la société et là vous voyez que de toute
évidence vous avez des jeunes qui ne
l'acceptent pas en elle-même alors
réponse de lexie agresti sachant qu'il
faut bien comprendre que l'on soit
trente hommes outrance femmes on peut
être transmis outrance femmes en étant
homosexuel donc aussi l'être en étant
hétérosexuels on peut l'être en étant
bisexuelle moi par exemple je suis
peut-être une lesbienne exemple le fait
que je touche avec des femmes c'est
peut-être que je suis une lesbienne je
plaisante qu'à moitié il ya des jeux de
garçons aujourd'hui qui se déclare comme
lesbienne et on a bien fêté ça pose mais
il ya des tas de choses qui c'est pour
ça qu'ils sont succédé sur passionnante
mais je vous laisse répondre les qui est
agressée à ce que disait marc jobin
n'est pas ce que je dis moi ce n'est pas
l'importance mais ce qui me gêne
j'aurais absolument pas le temps de
répondre à tous à tout ce qui a été dire
ça demanderait peut-être trois émissions
moi je crois que ce qui est
effectivement terrible c'est cette ce le
fait de revenir à ses positions
réactionnaires de tout n'est qu'une
question de sexualité tout n'est qu'une
question corps est en fait que
finalement ce que ce que marie jo
explique c'est qu'elle ne reconnaît pas
la légitimité à être femme si on n'a pas
un certaine organe génital ce qui est
quand même ce que les combats féministes
ont en fait attaqué et ont essayé de
démanteler depuis des décennies je crois
qu'il ya une convergence qui se fait
naturellement d'un point de vue
politique entre au contraire la question
de la libération tracé de la libération
féminine en général parce que de toute
façon elles se superposent
nécessairement vu que nous sommes des
femmes je crois qu'en fait il n'y a pas
tellement de réponse à apporter on est
sur des lignes qui peuvent pas être
réconciliées je le crois
parce que parce qu'on est sur des
visions de la société tout à l'heure ma
région mentionnaient le fait qu'on vient
de quelque part qu'on hérite d'une
histoire qu'on vient d'une famille
effectivement mais l'histoire elle est
aussi écrite elle est écrite
politiquement elle est écrite
socialement et l'effacement d'une
diversité de genres et d'une présence
trans dans l'histoire mais médiévale en
occident c'est une réalité je crois que
si on en revenait à
des définitions plus clair et qu'on
faisait un travail peut être plus nuancé
ne serait ce que dans comment on
appréhende notre histoire et est
justement le conte a transmis pour
construire les identités quel espace on
a construit pour ceux se définir soi
même et centre définir on comprendrait
en fait que la question trans comme vous
la définissez c'est une question qui a
toujours été qui a toujours été là qui a
toujours été minoritaire je crois que il
faut pas se faire d'illusion sur le fait
qu'on parle de la libération d'une
minorité avec ce que ça implique
effectivement en travail de 2,2 de
lenteur en travail administratif un
travail de pédagogie mais que c'est
quand même l'histoire de re visibiliser
une réalité humaine qui a toujours
existé sur tous les continents et à
travers toutes les époques ne connut
oui bien sûr c'est une histoire
certainement longue et il n'est pas
question de retirer des droits mais il
n'empêche que justement s'il n'est pas
question de retirer des droits
effectivement pour les femmes je trouve
que c'est compliqué tu très très
compliqué comment est-ce que ce serait
possible d'avoir le sentiment qu'il ya
un espace qui est préservé pour les
activités sportives si on se retrouve
avec des personnes qui ont des décors
parce que je veux dire on peut on peut
fantasmer beaucoup de choses on peut
revivre les choses on peut accepter des
gens il n'empêche qui a aussi quelques
réalité corporelle qu'on peut pas tout à
fait balayer sous le tapis et des
différences qui sont réelles peut-être
qu'elles ont pas d'un petit d'importance
au sens que ce serait pas le genre ou
que sais-je
mais il n'empêche que
les corps existe existe vraiment et si
d'ailleurs le mot sexe existent ça vient
du latin c'est tout ce qui veut dire
couper parce que le sexe et c'est qu'ils
coupent l'humanité en 2 1 et la côté est
des hommes il est coté d'aia des femmes
ont tout retourné ça dans tous les sens
austin réalité
vous a permis de lui vous voulez
il ya aussi des personnes intersexe qui
sont systématiquement mobilier qui sont
utiles et à la naissance et qui vous
montre aussi que s'il existe
effectivement une réalité biologique
qu'il s'agit pas de nier il s'agit de la
rue définir et de l'avoir plus
subtilement la question la classe mini
sportif c'est effectivement un grand
débat je crois que elle est aussi très
encadré très contrôlés et qu'il existe
un vrai double standard dans comment l
approche il s'agit toujours de de taper
sur les femmes trans qui est très
transmises aux jeans en un sens alors
que des chartes existe on est parfois
mais contrôlé de façon médicamenteuse
pour accéder à des sports
et qu' il s'agit pas de le remettre en
légitime en cause mais qu'on réfléchit
jamais effectivement le fait de créer de
l'espace pour les hommes de france où
les personnes ordinaires qui voudrait
elle accéder à des sports je crois
qu'ils ont fait face à des doubles
standards constamment et que finalement
le contrôle
médical ne suffit pas parce qu'il se
double toujours d'une grille morale qui
se fait passer par l'appel au bon sens
par l'appel à la nature comme un ordre
des choses et que s'il s'agit pas de
retirer des droits encore que on le voit
en gris en pologne c'est une volonté qui
existent activement de retirer des
droits
en tout cas la possibilité d'en créer
pour exister de façon équitable elle
elle est quasiment impossible à
réfléchir ce qui m'étonne si je peux
dire une chose qu'il disait marie jo
c'est que quand même quand tu disais
tout à l'heure qu'il y à des jeunes
femmes lesbiennes qui sont agressés ont
importuné par des femmes trans et comme
tout parle on dirait que tous pensent
qu'ils sont des hommes sont des femmes
c'est pas mal difficile je veux dire ce
sont des fous mais c'est à dire on ne
peut pas dire tout de tout je veux dire
salaires encore une fois laissé sont
méchants sont des hommes s'ils sont bons
ils sont des femmes ce sont tes fins de
transe après ils sont pas tous comme ça
je veux dire il faut commencer à un
confort à ouvrir et sortir un peu des
stéréotypes des genres il peut y avoir
des amis qui sont qui sont
particulièrement
envahissante je vais dire pourquoi pas
mais la même chose bercy via s'il vient
je peux être une lesbienne absolument on
est bien d'accord je veux être une
lesbienne absolument voilà c'est ça que
ça pose un problème si je vais frapper à
la porte un club de lesbiennes qu'il
veut recevoir que des femmes la question
tous et par rapport à la position que
vous avez et comment vous justifiez
votre position comment vous sentez
comment vous comment vous parlez comment
sinon vous voyez sinon on est bien sûr
que c'est bien simple faire des
classifications si on fait des
classifications mes hommes par là et
femmes parlent à la discussion à camiers
et plus simple vous simplifie alors
qu'ils veulent imposer une vraie
question oui qu'il faut encore une fois
a trouvé une réponse il faut voir
pourquoi vous voudrez être lesbienne
qu'est ce que ça veut dire pour vous et
alors on va trouver une solution si on
ferme tout à la biologie et au genre
entendu comme classification fixe est
stable on perd toutes ses possibilités
et cette nouvelle forme d sexuelle des
sexualités et des genres nous nous ouvre
mais là aussi c'est un vrai casse-tête
vous le reconnaîtrez puisque en prison
par exemple aa je vais prendre un
exemple très provocateur mais un van
steyn qui va finir sa vie en prison
pourrait faire sa transition et demandé
à être mis dans dans la dans les prisons
pour femmes ben ça dépend encore une
fois délà de la position moi je crois
qu'il ya encore une fois les sujets une
fois qu'il a dix ont
trouvé à partir de son désir inconscient
son identité parce que l'identité n'est
pas les mois un jeu l'identité n'est pas
l'émoi identité moi je dis en symptômes
c'est à dire un rapport du désir
inconscient
lire son propre trauma subjectif donc à
partir de cette identité les sujets a
oscillé droit de dire moi en tant que
femme je vais dans un an dans une prison
pour femmes indipendente tellement
d'efforts de son club le corps alors il
reste deux minutes une courte conclusion
très temporaire bien entendu chacune
marie jo bonnet
oui moi je vous êtes en train de nier la
l'homosexualité là qu'est ce que c'est
qu'une lesbienne c'est une femme qui
désire une femme elle ne désire pas le
pénis je suis désolé vous avez des
réalités matérielles qui sont
indépassables
bon ça c'est le premier point je pense
que la question trans on ne peut pas
dire que c'est la question trans il y a
des trans très différents vraiment très
différents et des situations très
différentes et je pense que aujourd'hui
c'est révélateur d'un malaise social moi
je pense que c'est notre société qui
souffrent on sort on sort du pot vide là
on se rappelle du coup vite je pense
qu'il ya un mais il ya une vraie
souffrance sociale il ya un féminicide
sociale et c'est là-dessus qu'il faut
qu'on réfléchisse parce que il ya
beaucoup de gens qui souffrent il n'y a
pas simplement les trans et donc je je
suis content d'avoir rencontré
aujourd'hui
l'excès parce que vraiment je pense que
il ne fait pas enfin pour moi je veux
dire parce que il le problème c'est les
transactive east qui sont violents voyez
mais autrement il faut il faut vraiment
qu'on réfléchisse à tout ça parce que
c'est très important dans l'excès
oui je crois que là effectivement le
j'essaye de faire très vite
effectivement je crois qu'il faut
réfléchir communément je crois qu'il
faut réfléchir communément en en
écoutant aussi la parole des concernés
les personnes trans souffre on n'est pas
les seuls à souffrir c'est vrai mais il
ya une réalité qui est là et là où il ya
des féminicides il ya aussi des
féminicides qui sont spécifiquement
transphobes et que en fait juste le
balayer du revers de la main ça serait
être une violence de plus qui n'est
fondamentalement pas juste les animaux
elle n'a connu
je rejoins quand même marie jo bonnet
sur beaucoup d'aspects là qui ont été
abordés il semble qu'effectivement il ya
un moment où il faut aussi bien sûr ne
pas nier les femmes leurs besoins la
question de de l'homosexualité parce que
effectivement avec une mauvaise graine
on pourrait oublier qu' à la question de
l'homosexualité et qui ramène du coup là
une fois de plus voilà le corps le sexe
réel ça me paraît important et du coup
ça me paraît important qu effectivement
il ya des débats qui soient ouverts et
que tout ça commence à être discuté et
de manière aussi agréable et paul x a
été aujourd'hui
de manière à ce que justement toutes les
questions où je pense qu on aurait un
point d'accord tous sur le fait que
normalement on ne touche pas au corps
des enfants puisque je reviens sur le
sujet qui m'importe est bien devrait
être vraiment aucun de nos
préoccupations
on s'arrête là on est déjà à me déplacer
le temps qui nous était imparti je vous
remercie à toutes les quatre d'avoir
participé à cette émission merci de nous
avoir suivis et rendez vous au prochain
numéro
[Musique]